ein riesiges schiff kippt in einem
norwegischen fjord
innerhalb weniger minuten dran im
tausende tonnen wasser halten
das deck wurde plötzlich
die suche nach überlebenden
dabei ein klopp zeigte wo wird zu einem
wettlauf gegen die zeit jemand ist
jemand ist eingeschlossen eine der
größten untersuchungen in der
norwegischen schifffahrt beginnt
meine letzte nachricht wahr macht
schnell mein kollege stirbt
[Musik]
an norwegens westküste fahren jeden tag
hunderte schiffe durch die englische
oder und kanäle
die routen führen zu den meistbefahrenen
wasserstraßen europas und sind extrem
gefährlich
[Musik]
es ist nicht leicht durch diese gewässer
zu fahrten in den fjorden gibt es viele
sehr enge passagen so dass man besonders
vorsichtig sein muss
[Musik]
19 januar 2004 riesige frachter roc
nation ist auf dem weg vom norwegischen
eigenfett wir bergen in die nordsee und
soll von dort weiter nach unten
[Musik]
kapitän jan juwi kommandiert das schiff
mit seiner 30 köpfigen besatzung
wie geht's voran lotsen
trotz neuester sicherheitstechnik an
bord nutzte kapitän die dienste des
ortsansässigen lotsen wermuth alien um
durch den engen für uns zu kommen
ja alles gut wir sind voll im plan
kapitän barry lust ist experte für
schiffs navigation und weiß wie wichtig
ein guter lotse ist
[Musik]
der lotse kennt das gebiet wie seine
westentasche viele kapitäne überlassen
den lotsen gleich das ganze schiff weil
sie wissen dass er sich auf der
vorgesehenen route im zweifel besser
auskennt als sie selbst
mallien navigiert drobnys durch die
engen fjorde um ins offene meer zu
gelangen so wie er es mit anderen
schiffen schon hunderte male zuvor getan
hat
die rockies ist ein spezial gefährt das
steine auf dem meeresgrund ausschüttet
mit 166 metern länge gilt sie als das
größte stein stürzer shift der welt
sie hatte im frachtraum stein schuld der
sie mit hilfe einer förderanlage und
einem fallrohr das bis unter das schiff
reicht der punktgenau stoppen konnte
das dient dem schutz von unterwasser
pipelines und anderen unterwasser
projekten
das schiff kann riesige mengen steiner
transportieren doch es ist dadurch auch
schwer zu steuern
kapitän jan bosse war lotse auf der rock
ness und weiß um ihre eigenheiten
eine große schwierigkeit war die
schlechte sicht von der brücke aus
wenn sie ihn wolltest was vor dem schiff
passiert hast du eigentlich nur auf die
aufbauten gebucht
für eine freie sicht muss der lotse von
einer seite der brücke zu anderen gehen
stell dir vor du fährst die straße
runter und vor dir mitten auf der
motorhaube sitzt ein riesiger klotz
nur noch wenige minuten bis ins offene
meer die rock 'n' es muss aber vorher
noch den felsigen bett lässt raumfahrt
passieren
[Musik]
sehr eng um sicher durch zu kommen muss
man genau in der mitte bleiben
doch die strömung in dem schon ist
unberechenbar
die strömung im westen verläuft in
unterschiedliche richtungen
da ist es mitunter schwierig das schiff
auf kurs zu halten
8x unter der brücke befindet sich der
riesige fast 10.000 ps starke
dieselmotor
die männer sorgen dafür dass das schiff
immer genug antrieb halt einer von ihnen
ist der schiffs elektriker
unsere mannschaft arbeitete schon seit
längerer zeit zusammen deswegen konnten
wir uns gut das waren alles gute jungs
wie die meisten an bord stammt mengen
safe von den philippinen
sie kamen von anderen ende der welt und
arbeitete monatelang auf den schiffen
getrennt von ihren familien
von ihrem haus aus beobachten giesel
mellum und seine frau wie die riesige
rockets durch den fährt
meine frau und ich hatten gerade zu
abend gegessen und sahen die rockers
guck dir das ding an riesig groß
das war eines der größten schiffe das
wir je im bett lässt formen gesehen
hatten also den garaus und machten ein
foto
auf der brücke leitet der lotse die
fahrten in fürth 1
[Musik]
doch irgendetwas stimmte nicht
magst du das wir haben schlagseite der
lotse bemerkte eine leichte kränkung
nach steuerbord mal sehen was hier los
ist
wie sieht es nun so aus oder neigt sie
sich noch eine seite
hier stimmt etwas nicht ganz und gar
nicht
meine werkzeuge fielen herunter also
ging ich in den kontrollraum dort sah
ich den dritten ingenieur
hast du das gemerkt und
ich sage wir haben schlagseite
das schiff neigt sich bedrohlich nach
steuerbord und
tippt immer weiter
ich habe das sos signal gehört und
fragte mich was zum teufel los ist
das schiff hat schwere schlagseite
wo gott
das boot kippte darum nahm ich die
kamera wieder hoch
je mehr der frachter schlagseite bekommt
desto wahrscheinlicher ist es dass
erkenntnis panik auf der brücke
der lotse hofft dass eine scharfe kurve
das schiff wieder aufrichten kann doch
er hofft vergebens
bekamen der kapitän merkte schnell dass
es hier um leben und tod ging
hier spricht der kapitän
wir rannten die leiter hoch nur nach
oben
der maschinenraum befindet sich im
untersten deck
[Musik]
wir rannten zu den notausgängen
den geholten am leben bleiben
[Musik]
es gibt
die mayday mayday wir quält dann nimmt
jochen
[Musik]
große gegenstände flogen herum
jeder versucht er sich irgendwo
festzuhalten
der lud sie wusste dass sie in wenigen
sekunden kentern würden also versucht er
zur tür zu kommen
der lotse schaffte es von der brücke
nach draußen zu kommen unterdessen
versuchen die männer unter deck
verzweifelt die notausgänge zu erreichen
wir versuchten über leitern und ohren
raus zu klettern
das deck wurde plötzlich zu decken
während das schiff umkippt rettet sich
der lotse über das geländer und klettert
auf die seite
die seite des chefs hinauf um auf den
kiel zu kommen bevor das schiff komplett
kenterte
noch vor einer minute war der
schiffsrumpf unter wasser jetzt stand
der lotse obendrauf
die rock 'n' es hat sich um 180 grad
gedreht
[Musik]
vom kapitän und den schiffsoffiziere
fehlt jede spur der nutzer hat es gerade
noch von der brücke nach draußen
geschafft
[Musik]
innerhalb von vier minuten ist ein 166
meter langes schiff mitsamt seiner 30
köpfigen besatzung umgekippt und treibt
jetzt kiel
rettungsmannschaften suchen im eiskalten
wasser nach überlebenden
[Musik]
niemand ahnt dass der elektriker und
zwei seiner kollegen im schiff
eingeschlossen sind
[Musik]
in diesem moment habe ich nur gebetet
ich betete wenn du mich zu dir nimmst
bitte hilf meiner familie und leite sie
es gibt wenig sauerstoff ihre einzige
hoffnung ist dass sie gefunden werden
bevor es zu spät ist es muss ein
unfassbarer anblick gewesen sein dieses
riesige schiff das vor aller augen im
fjord kieloben schwamm vor den häusern
der leute die alles mit angesehen hat
in der ersten halben stunde werden
sieben überlebende aus dem wasser
gezogen
zwei weitere unter ihnen auch der lotse
warm und halim werden mit hubschraubern
vom rumpf gerettet
doch von 21 besatzungsmitgliedern fehlt
jede spur
das war sie live lände leitet den
einsatz der rettungstaucher er hat
jahrelange erfahrung doch so etwas hat
er noch nie gesehen das war eine große
sache die völlig unerwartet kam darauf
waren wir nicht vorbereitet
sie mussten rauskriegen ob noch jemand
im rumpf gefangen war und wenn ja wo
die rettungsmannschaften und kreisen das
havarierte schiff und achten auf
geräusche oder mögliche rufe
sie konnten verletzt sein und das wasser
war kalt
es gibt überlebende ich habe klopfen
gehört zeigt mir wo ein schwaches
geräusch facht die hoffnung der retter
an jemand ist am leben jemand ist
eingeschlossen
judith mel c und zwei seiner kollegen
haben in einer luftblase nahe des
maschinenraums überlebt wo früher unten
war ist jetzt oben
ich hielt mich an den rohren fest und
klopfte mit dem schraubenzieher gegen
die decke um lärm zu machen
wir hoffen dass die einsatzkräfte uns
retten würden
sie hatten rolf liegende gegenstände
überlebt aber eine hatte den arm
gebrochen die drei hielten sich an einer
leiter fest
als das schiff umkippte wurden ihre
fluchtwege geflutet wir versuchten
herauszukommen aber das wasser stieg
immer weiter
wie wir verloren langsam die hoffnung
weil es keine fluchtwege mehr gab
doch sie haben glück im unglück bei der
schrauben welle hat sich eine luftblase
gebildet
dort harren sie aus ohne zu wissen wie
lange der sauerstoff reicht oder ob das
wasser weiter steigt
die idee woher das klopfen kommt keine
ahnung es hat sogar alt
ende muss herausfinden wo die geräusche
gehört
[Musik]
das problem war dass das klopfen
nachhallte
166 meter stahlen das ist wie eine echo
kammer wenn jemand klopft weißt du nicht
wo das geräusch herkommt okay machen wir
einen plan ich denke
es kommt hier aus dieser sektion
ende geht davon aus dass etwaige
überlebende sich in der nähe des
maschinenraums aufhalten könnten doch
die zeit rennt ihnen davon
es war sehr schwierig dort zu atmen es
roch nach abgasen und chemikalien
und heißes öl tropfte von der decke
deswegen mussten die retter sie so
schnell wie möglich da raus holen
zentimeter für zentimeter suchen landes
männer den rumpf nach der geräuschquelle
ab doch dann gibt es ein weiteres
problem
die strömung im fjord ist zwischen drei
und vier knoten schnell das heißt die
rocken es ist denn bewegen auch wenn sie
kieloben liegt
das treibende fragt könnte jeden moment
ganz untergehen ende muss reagieren
verstanden unsere leute daraus
arbeit einstellen er bricht die aktion
ab
es bestand die gefahr dass das schiff
sinkt und die rettungskräfte mit
hinunter reist wir können nichts machen
solange wir das schiff nicht gesichert
haben es ist zu gefährlich
die retter müssen versuchen den tausende
tonnen schweren koloss an land zu ziehen
doch sie müssen behutsam vorgehen sonst
könnten die luftlöcher entweichen die
die männer am leben und das schiff kiel
oben halten
für die männer im rumpf zählt jede
minute
wir haben weiter lärm gemacht und
gerufen
es hat aufgehört es hat aufgehört nach
zwei quälend lange stunden ist die
rockers endlich am ufer
für landis männer heißt das zurück an
die arbeit
hast du das gehört ja
ich habe jede sekunde geklopft
rettern ein zeichen zu geben
[Musik]
helfer
ihr seht hier
bis sie uns fanden
da
[Musik]
wir kommen
wir waren so froh als die retter uns
entdeckten
da dachten wir wir werden es schaffen
wir müssen sehr behutsam vorgehen
retter und besatzung sind nur durch eine
stahlwand getrennt doch lände muss mit
bedacht agieren
sie müssen aufpassen dass sie nicht ein
kraftstofftank oder andere potenzielle
gefahrenherde erwischen damit nichts in
die luft flog
der einsatzleiter muss exakt die
richtige stelle treffen
wenn wir das schiff an der falschen
stelle geöffnet hätten wäre die luft
entwichen und das schiff gekentert
wir bohren ein loch und gucken
die eingeschlossene luft ist das einzige
was die rock 'n' es an der oberfläche
und die männer am leben sind ein loch an
der falschen stelle könnte ihre blase
fluten und zu ihrem tod führen
komprimierte luft strömt aus dem
bohrloch
das pfeifende entweichenden luft ist
ohrenbetäubend
ferner macht jede verständigung
unmöglich also schreiben die retter
zettel um herauszufinden ob sie den
rumpf aufschneiden können
[Musik]
meine beiden kollegen waren sehr schwach
einer hat am kopf stark geblutet
in meiner letzten notiz schrieb ich
mein kollege stirbt
wir dürfen keine zeit verlieren los
geht's
wenn es männer beginnen den rumpf
aufzuschneiden
die schweissen den stahl auf bohne zu
wissen was passiert
die ganze gefangenen luft drückt jetzt
nach oben
soweit sie ein loch rein schneiden wird
die luft heraus strömen und der
wasserpegel steigen
schnee
raus mit ihnen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
alle drei männer werden herausgezogen
sekunden später ist das wort
vollgelaufen sie sind die letzten
besatzungsmitglieder die lebend geborgen
werden ich werde diesen anblick und
seinen gesichtsausdruck nie vergessen
ich habe mich bei ihm bedankt und mein
retter sagte schubert du hast glück dass
du überlebt hast
ich bin so dankbar dafür
insgesamt zwölf besatzungsmitglieder der
rockets haben das unglück überlebt
18 männer darunter der kapitän kommen
ums leben
die familien der 18 toten wollten wissen
wie das passieren konnte
der druck auf die ermittler ist hoch
warum ist die rox gekentert
einen tag nach dem tragischen
schiffsunglück stehen norwegische
polizei taucher vor einer schwierigen
aufgabe
sie müssen die leichen aus dem wrack der
rockies bergen ehe das schiff aus dem
chor geschleppt wird
18 menschen haben hier den tod gefunden
die polizei will wissen warum der
stellvertretende polizeichef von bergens
wenn ihre krupp rollt leitet die
ermittlungen
die polizei wollte wissen wie es zu dem
unglück gekommen war und ob es
strafrechtlich relevante faktoren gab
etwa in bezug auf die navigation die
verteilung der fracht oder andere gründe
verschiedene zeugen haben das geschehen
verfolgt darunter auch diesel meldung
ich habe alles fotografiert
seine fotoserie zeigt wie der
riesenfrachter sich um seine eigene
achse dreht und schließlich kiel oben
treibt
ermittler aus drei ländern sollen das
rätsel vom untergang der rock nist lösen
sie wundern sich vor allem wie schnell
das schiff gesunken ist
[Musik]
merkwürdig wie kann ein so großes schiff
so schnell kenter auch hans-joachim
müller aus bremerhaven ist mit der
untersuchung des unglücks betraut
ein bisschen ist das schiff innerhalb
von vier minuten gesunken das ist sehr
ungewöhnlich normalerweise passiert so
etwas nicht in vier minuten
irgendetwas hat ein loch in die seite
der box gerissen doch wie kam es dazu
[Musik]
der schiffsboden auf der steuerbordseite
bei auf einer länge von 20 metern
aufgerissen
die ermittler errechnen dass bei einem
loch dieser größe etwa 600 tonnen wasser
pro minute in das schiff einbringen das
ist eine menge wasser aber für ein
schiff das 166 meter lang ist geht das
noch das loch ist nicht groß genug um
das schnelle kentern zu erklären es muss
einen anderen grund geben
mein erster gedanke war dass etwas mit
der stabilität des schiffs nicht stimmte
es stellt sich heraus dass die rockers
umgebaut und erst vor acht monaten
wieder vom stapel gelassen wurde
es war ein massengutfrachter der
zumstein stürze umgebaut worden war
[Musik]
beim umbau wurden 3000 tonnen schwere
eisen aufbauten auf dem deck installiert
das ist ein enormes gerecht
die zusätzlichen aufbauten an deck haben
die gesamte stabilität des schiffs
verändert
hat die kopflastige bauweise zum
blitzartigen untergang der rox geführt
[Musik]
um diese frage zu beantworten benötigen
die ermittler die computer aus dem
havarierten schiff
es war wichtig an die dort gespeicherten
informationen zu kommen um die
ereignisse zu rekonstruieren
doch die empfindliche technik ist von
salz wasser geflutet niemand weiß ob die
daten noch brauchbar sind
während die ermittler auf die
datenrettung warten will die polizei in
bergen herausfinden ob der lotse
verantwortung für das unglück trägt
vielen dank dass sie gekommen sind
unsere befragung war sehr formell und
wir führten ihn offiziell auch als
verdächtigen
[Musik]
erzählen sie uns alles woran sie sich
erinnern
beginnen sie mit dem moment als sie an
bord gingen
bis zum kentern
er war ja der einzige überlebende von
der brücke und konnte uns mit sehr
wichtigen informationen versorgen
ich kannte die gegend gut und machte mir
keine sorgen wie war die sicht auf der
brücke die sicht war nicht überragend
aber ich kam zu recht hat
der lotse zählte polizei dass es ein tag
wie jeder andere
[Musik]
bruder buck 5 grad
backbord 5 grad pauli am sagt es gab
eigentlich keine probleme nur zu anfang
der fahrt hätte sich die rockers einmal
zur seite geneigt
das gemerkt war vielleicht die fracht
sie kamen zu dem schluss dass die fracht
nach steuerbord geputzt sein musste und
das schiff danach dauerhaft schlagseite
hatte
die rock 'n' es hatte mehr als 23.000
tonnen gestein schutt geladen sie sind
in sechs riesigen laderäumen
untergebracht jeder so groß wie ein
vierstöckiges haus
wenn das schiff ungleich beladen wurde
könnte es dadurch schlagseite bekommen
haben
die neigung ist minimal das sollte kein
problem sein der low zu sagt aus dass
der kapitän kein grund zur sorge sei und
die fahrt fortsetzte kurs halten
die nächsten sechs stunden verliefen
ohne weitere probleme dann vor dir ob es
eine kurve
[Musik]
plötzlich hörten sie ein kratzen des
knirschen
das schiff vibrierte
aufprall
hast du das gespürt
ich glaube wir hatten bodenberührung
herr bodenberührung
das war das schlimmste was man einem
lotsen sagen kann auf grund zu laufen
ist mit das schlimmste für ein schiff
der kapitän ging zu der zeit davon aus
dass man den schaden minimieren kann
wenn man die wasserdichten schotten
schließt
weder der kapitän noch sonst jemand auf
der brücke ahnte dass das schiff kentern
würde
mal sehen was hier los ist sie wussten
dass es etwas ernstes ist die rock 'n'
es ist mit wasserdichten schott wänden
versehen das sollte ihnen zeit
verschaffen und das problem zu lösen
laut ferien hätten er und der kapitän
sofort maßnahmen zur rettung des schiffs
ergriffen
doch das schiff neigte sich weiter und
weiter nach steuerbord
der lotse versucht das ruder so weit wie
möglich herumzureißen
vergebens das schiff neigt sich immer
mehr zur seite
für die männer an bord muss das
furchtbar gewesen sein
dem lotsen dann klar dass das schiff
nicht mehr zu retten war
[Musik]
er lief direkt zur tür
das rettet ihm das leben
doch für die polizei stellt sich die
frage ob er das unglück zu verantworten
hat
sie sagen
[Musik]
dass sie auf kurs waren
ich war auf großes
pallien ist sich keiner schuld bewusst
es gab dort eine untiefe die auf keiner
karte verzeichnet ist
könnte der lotse recht haben oder will
sich rausreden
wir schauen uns das an
ich bin polizist und kein lotse oder
kapitän aber das hatte mich verblüfft
[Musik]
danke dass sie hier waren
das waren der neue heiße spur bei
unseren ermittlungen
die polizei verfolgt zwei theorien
entweder der lotse hat gelogen und war
in wirklichkeit nicht auf kurs oder das
kartenmaterial von einem der wichtigsten
wasserwege norwegens ist falsch und
viele weitere leben sind in gefahr
zwei monate nach der havarie der rock
'n' es wird das umgekippte vag an land
gezogen und ausgeschlachtet
hat der lotse das unglück verursacht war
das schiff durch die aufbauten zu
kopflastig oder ist das kartenmaterial
falsch
die ermittler hoffen dass die computer
der rockies aufschluss geben taucher
haben einige geborgen andere sind noch
im rat
die ermittler hofften dass die computer
noch in ordnung waren obwohl sie
herumgewirbelt wurden und im salzwasser
lagen sie hofften dass sie die daten von
den entscheidenden momenten vor dem
unfall noch nutzen konnten
der it-experte finnland ist mit der
datenrettung betraut
das war eher wettlauf gegen die zeit
durch das salz korrodieren die
festplatten sehr schnell und dann wird
es schwierig die daten noch heraus zu
bekommen doch bevor die spezialisten an
bord gehen muss das schiff erst
aufgerichtet werden durch ein verfahren
das paar bertling genannt wird
ein so großes schiff und zu drehen ist
ein sehr schwieriges und gefährliches
unterfangen vor diesem unglück wurden
nur wenige große schiffe mit diesem
verfahren geworden
mehrere schwere schleppte sowie ein kran
sind im einsatz um die rockies
aufzurichten reist eines dicken
stahlseilen könnte es zur katastrophe
kommen
das schiff dürfe auf keinen fall zurück
kippen und niemand sollte verletzt oder
getötet werden es war alles sehr riskant
nach zwei tagen ist die rockies
aufgerichtet
endlich können die experten an bord
gehen um die letzten computer zu bergen
jeder hat eine eigene geschichte zu
erzählen
es gab navigations computer und fracht
computer die als beweisstücke beide von
großem interesse für uns waren die
navigationsdaten könnten zeigen ob die
rockies vom kurs abgekommen ist und ob
den lotsen irgendeine schuld trifft die
lade daten wiederum könnten hinweise auf
die stabilität des schiffes liefern
die männer müssen mehrfach auf die
völlig zerstörte brücke um alle rechner
zu bergen
auch tourist emre gehört zu dem
ermittlungsteam an bord
ich habe mich wie einen eindringlingen
gefühlt ich wusste was dort passiert war
und gehörte da irgendwie nicht hin
[Musik]
überall lagen zerschmetterte gegenstände
herum
das war schon eine unheimliche erfahrung
schließlich sind da 18 menschen
gestorben
unvorstellbar was für schmerzen angst
die leute gehabt haben müssen
unter trümmern begraben finden die
ermittler schließlich wonach sie suchen
endlich hatten wir die richtigen
computer gefunden
mehr licht
es war unglaublich wie viel noch da war
wenn es anhaltspunkte zum hergang des
unfalls geben soll dann sind die
festplatten ein vielversprechender
lagerplatz dafür
die computer sind in schlechtem zustand
uwe nieland hat die schwierige aufgabe
in ihre geheimnisse zu entlocken
[Musik]
du versuchst alles mit all deinen
instrumenten und all deiner erfahrung um
die platten wieder zum leben zu erwecken
ein fehler und die platte ist hin
vorsichtig wird die empfindliche
elektronik gesäubert und getrocknet dann
beginnt der mühsame prozess der
datenrettung
[Musik]
das ist wie bei einem puzzle wo man die
teile zusammen suchen muss nur dass es
auf der festplatte millionen und
abermillionen von teilen gibt
die rekonstruktion der daten dauert
monate ob sie die ermittler aber
wirklich weiterbringen stellt sich erst
beim letzten download heraus
[Musik]
sie haben glück das war ein
unbeschreiblicher moment für das team
gute arbeit
da wussten wir dass wir die daten hatten
um das rätsel zu lösen
die ermittler werten die daten sofort
aus
lotsen arbeiten mit speziellen seekarten
in denen die tiefe des jeweiligen
gewässers verzeichnet ist anhand dieser
karten finden sie den richtigen fahrweg
innerhalb der sicherheitszone und
vermeiden so felsige und tiefen dicht
unter der wasseroberfläche
die ermittler rekonstruieren auf der
karte den fahrweg bis zu dem moment als
das schiff kenterte
hat vermont ali m die rockies ins
verderben genutzt oder stimmt seine
version dass eine nicht markierte
gefahrenstelle schuld war
guck dir all die kursänderungen an
in fällt sofort auf dass der lotse ohne
gründlich viele kleine kurskorrekturen
vorgenommen hat statt wenige große zu
machen
kommen zeigte wasser
oder 5 grad nach backbord besten kurz
vor der einfahrt in den westen führt
rechts sich seine strategie
da
sieht aus als würde er zu spät drehen
[Musik]
er ist die kurve zu spät gefahren so
dass das schiff zu weit südlich kamen
das heißt er ist in den roten bereich
bekommen so viel lässt sich das ist
verschoben die späte wende trägt die
rockers mindestens 23 meter weit aus der
sicherheitszone heraus
doch warum man der lotse leichtsinnig
oder gab es einen anderen grund der
wenig später zur katastrophe führte
die wiederhergestellten navigationsdaten
des frachters zeigen dass die rock 'n'
es kurz vor dem unglück in ihr verl ich
seichtes wasser geraten ist
die ermittler wollen herausfinden warum
thurid stelle vermutet dass verrutschte
ladung zu einer instabilität des chefs
geführt haben könnte das würde auch
erklären warum der frachter probleme bei
den wendemanövern hatte
um die stabilität der rogers im moment
des unglücks zu beurteilen mussten wir
genau wissen wie sie beladen wollte
wenn das schiff instabil war dann hätte
es eine warnung geben müssen wir wussten
dass die stabilität normalerweise anhand
gewisser kriterien vor verlassen des
hafens kontrolliert wird
hat hier mal an
die daten belegen dass es nach der
beladung im hafen einen warnhinweis gab
die stabilitäts berechnung der rockers
zeigte dass es eine ernst zunehmende
instabilität gab
die neigung betrug da schon 14 grad
das heißt dass die stabilität des
schiffs nicht gewährleistet war so hätte
es eigentlich nicht losfahren dürfen die
ermittler mutmaßen dass ein schadhaftes
förderband ursache für die ungleiche
beladung gewesen sein könnte
das problem war das förderband und
transportsystem in lahde hafen nicht
lang genug waren so landete ein großteil
der fracht nur auf einer seite die
ungleich verteilte ladung cut das schiff
auf eine seite gedrückt und zu einem
warnhinweis auf der brücke geführt
[Musik]
die katastrophe wäre also vermeidbar
gewesen
startklar
der erste offizier an bord hätte seine
leute mit harke und schaufel losschicken
sollen damit sie den
gesteinsschicht im ganzen frachtraum
verteilen
das ist nie passiert die ermittler haben
einen schlimmen verdacht stadt die lose
fracht von hand umzuschichten hat die
brücken crew tonnen von wasser in die
ballasttanks auf der steuerbordseite
gepumpt und die neigung des schiffs
dadurch korrigiert
das war bestenfalls flickschusterei
die gefahr dabei ist dass die ladung von
einer seite auf die andere rutschen kann
wenn das schiff in den seeweg einfährt
und genau das ist passiert kurz bevor
die rockers in den wettlisten 4 und
eingefahren ist die ladung ist verwischt
und das schiff hat sich nach steuerbord
geneigt
das kopflastige schiff wird dadurch noch
schwerer zu steuern
wenn du mit einem schiff der schlagseite
hat eine wende fährst dann wird es
schneller und dann kann man die
kontrolle über das schiff verlieren
durch eine scharfe lenkbewegung kann die
fracht noch weiter verrutschen und die
schlagseite verschlimmern der lotse
entscheidet daher einen größeren bogen
zu fahren fünf grad mehr nach backbord
er steuert die rockies 23 meter hinter
die sicherheitslinie der fahrrinne
darauf vertrauen dass das wasser dort
noch immer tief genug ist
alle anderen schiffe bitte hinter uns
bleiben
polizeitaucher haben den boden des
fjords abgesucht um die genaue stelle zu
finden an der die rock 'n' es auf grund
gelaufen ist
wenn du einen mord untersucht gehst du
in eine wohnung und sichert den tatort
hier war der tatort so groß wie zwei
fußballfelder da kann man keine
polizeiabsperrung drumrum machen das
machte die sache aus polizeilicher sicht
natürlich ziemlich schwierig
aber noch zweitägiger suche haben die
ermittler gefunden wonach sie suchen
die taucher fanden einen 20 kilo
schweren stein mit roter farbe dabei auf
eine ähnliche fandel wie das rot am
boden der rogers
der stein lag unweit der stelle an der
die rockers ihren kurs verlassen hatte
sollte die rocken es hier auf grund
gelaufen sein wäre die frage nach der
unglücksursache endgültig beantwortet ab
ins labor damit
[Musik]
im labor wird das beweisstück forensisch
untersucht
es stellt sich heraus die farbe auf dem
stein ist identisch mit der vom
schiffsrumpf
damit war klar dass das schiff an dieser
stelle dem fels gestreift hatte die
unglücksstelle liegt 23 meter außerhalb
der sicherheitszone doch der lotse
behauptet dass keine gefahrenstelle in
seiner karte verzeichnet war diese und
tiefe ist auf keiner karte zu sehen
als die ermittler sich das
kartenmaterial ansehen machen sie eine
schockierende entdeckung
zwar wurde die untiefe in einer auflage
die neun jahre zuvor aktualisiert worden
war eingezeichnet doch die untiefe
selbst ist kaum zu erkennen und die
aktualisierung wurde den örtlichen
dutzend nie kommuniziert
das norwegische schifffahrtsamt hatte
den seeleuten nicht mitgeteilt dass eine
neue und tiefe aufgetaucht war und man
diese gefahrenstelle von hand in die
karten eintragen sollte
das ist die haupt chefs gute nach werden
hier fahren so viele scheffel warum
wurden die seeleute die kapitäne und
lotsen nicht verständigt
es hätte den lotsen aus der gegend
irgendwie mitgeteilt werden müssen es
war ein versäumnis das letztendlich 18
menschen das leben gekostet hat
nach monatelangen ermittlungen ist klar
dass eine reihe von fehlern letztendlich
zum kennt an der box geführt hat
[Musik]
alles was schief laufen konnte ist
schief gelaufen
zuerst wurde das schiff falsch beladen
und hatte schieflage
partner
dann verrutschte die ladung
hast du das gemerkt
vielleicht die ladung das schiff bekam
schlagseite und der lotse konnte keine
enge kurven erfahren
5 grad nach backbord
ohne sich eine gefahr bewusst zu sein
leitete der lotse die kurve zu spät ein
und steuerte in unmarkierten wasser
sie konnten später riss ein felsen die
schiffsführer auf
innerhalb weniger minuten strömten
tausende tonnen wasser in das schiff
nach dem wassereinbruch gab es keine
rettung mehr für das riesige schiff
kenterte dramatisch schnell
[Musik]
in dem moment als die rockers die felsen
streifte war ihr schicksal besiegelt
die seeleute hatten keine chance 18
menschen starben
[Musik]
die meisten schiffsunfälle sind das
resultat vieler kleiner fehler die zu
einer kettenreaktion führen
in ihrem abschlussbericht fordern die
behörden strengere verordnungen bei der
beladung von schiffen
vermont arjen wird nicht belangt und
arbeitet weiter als lotse
trotzdem diese last muss er bis zum ende
seiner tage mit sich tragen
der wettlisten fjord wurde nach dem
unglück der rauch muss ausgebaggert um
die sicherheit größere schiffe zu
erhöhen
[Musik]
doch auch die dramatische rettungsaktion
bleibt in der innung
der überlebenswille der drei philippiner
die in der dunkelheit immer wieder gegen
die schiffs warten bis sie eine antwort
bekam
und die anstrengungen der
rettungsmannschaften die wie malz
aufgaben das ist eine bemerkenswerte
geschichte die von überlebens willen und
einsatz zeigt
wenn ich an die rockets denke dann
vergesse ich tränen für die 18 männer
meine kollegen die ihr leben verloren
haben ich vermisse sie und bete für ihre
seelen